Now there's other things that are going on with chronic fatigue, not just the genes
of getting energy production out of the mitochondrial, right?
And that's how we get into detoxification pathways that are so important.
These are more mitochondrial genes that we look at.
So there's a lot of genes to look at, right?
Detoxification with cancer and chronic life is essential.
So I said earlier that you really are what you absorb, you're not what you eat,
you are what you absorb.
Well actually better is you are what you absorb, you are what you do not detoxify, right?
So you absorb a lot of things, not just through your gut, but through your breathing
or through injections and things like that.
If you can get it out of your body, if it's not good for you, then it doesn't become a part of you.
But if you can't get it out of your body, through your detoxification pathways,
then it doesn't become a part of you.
So we don't want bad things becoming a part of us.
So you have specific detoxification pathways that's what I'm going to talk about.
Your first one is maybe one of your more important ones is your SOD pathway.
Here they're showing three, no, I think we have 13 in the pathway.
SOD gene makes superoxide dismutase.
Superoxide dismutase is a very important chemical in your body
because what it does is it scavenges a specific free radical,
meaning that it goes and grabs onto this free radical superoxide and it pulls it out of the body.
That's the whole purpose of superoxide dismutase.
Very important because too many free radicals in our body could cause cancer, could cause fatigue, could cause all sorts of symptoms.
So free radicals are bad, so I'm going to take a bunch of antioxidants.
Superoxide dismutase is an antioxidant that's made in your body.
It grabs onto superoxide and it turns it into hydrogen peroxide.
And then glutehyl, which we'll talk about in a little bit, grabs onto that,
along with catalysts, turns it into water and gets it out of the body and you're at a doubt.
So your body is making superoxide iodide.
Ever I said before that everything is about balance, you actually need free radicals in your body.
What I said are free radicals are bad.
Well they are, if you got too many of them.
But not having free radicals is bad too.
You actually make superoxide through the maternity pathway, but it's supposed to have a very short life span.
So the half life of superoxide is very short.
Why? Because you're supposed to have really healthy superoxide dismutase genes
that make a bunch of superoxide dismutase that get rid of it.
So it does its job, it helps kill pathogens and then your body gets rid of it.
So very important.
So if I have defects on my superoxide dismutase gene, I'm not making enough SOD.
So I can have excess amounts of superoxide ions.
Well that's not good because I can cause cancer and I can cause a whole bunch of different things.
Well the story gets even worse.
If I have a chronic infection like Lyme disease, then I have excess other chemical called
inducible nitric oxide synthase.
Sorry, it's really boring.
But this excess nitric oxide readily binds to excess superoxide.
And it makes this really nasty guy called peroxidite trait.
Proxidite trait is extremely damaging to your endothelial cells.
That's the cells that lie in your blood vessels.
It's extremely damaging to all cells.
It can damage the cell membrane.
And even if I have really super healthy by no unreal genes that we looked at just a second ago,
the proxidite trait is damaging the cell membranes so those nutrients can't even get in.
Proxidite trait in excess may be the very cause of trigromyalgia type symptoms.
It is one of the principal causes of heart disease.
Heart disease is still the number one cause of death in the United States.
So proxidite trait formation and controlling proxidite trait formation is extremely important.
That's why I said this SOD gene is really important.
Even if you don't have chronic line, there's a lot of people dying of heart disease on a daily basis.
They don't have chronic line.
However, that's why chronic other some acute, some clinical eating not ever diagnosed infections like each pylori
are the cause of heart disease solely through this very process.
I shouldn't say that.
There's another process that is involved too.
But big part of it is through proxidite trait formation.
Okay?
Story gets worse.
There's another gene called your NOSG that's in a pathway called your biopter and pathway.
And that NOSG is responsible for another type of nitric oxide synthase called endothelial nitric oxide synthase.
And another one called neuronal nitric oxide synthase.
That's for making nitric oxide into the brain for...
Nitric oxide is actually a good guy.
In the brain for a neuronal tissue in the endothelial cells, it's a very good guy.
It helps open up and relax the smooth muscles in the endothelial cells.
It helps you decrease high blood pressure.
However, if you have superoxide, I am floating around.
It's attaching it for the proxidite trait.
If you have NOS defects, which we'll talk about in a little bit,
you have uncoupled nitric oxide, which can bond to superoxide.
So I know it's super complicated.
I just lost half of you guys.
But when you have SODG defects,
you have to support these whether you have symptoms or not.
So I don't have heart disease.
I don't care.
So I don't have fibromyalgia.
You have SODG defects.
We're going to support this.
Because most people that have heart disease, how do they only have heart disease?
They died.
So it's not a good idea to wait on it.
Does that make sense?
So this is an important pathway to support.
Here's the pathway if you like chemistry.
I love chemistry.
So superoxide dismitase gene.
Every one of these genes needs different nutrients to push the gene pathway.
This needs copper, zinc, and magnesium to push this pathway.
So one of the things if I have a bunch of defects,
I may want to use nutrients to help support that.
Now the beauty is, some of these genes you cannot give end products.
Like if I have some defects in the methaniety pathways,
so I'm not making enough sand, which we'll talk about in a bit.
You can't just give sand.
You can buy it in the store, but I don't recommend using it.
But SOD does not work on a negative feedback loop.
So you could give them a person straight SOD.
And catalysts in glutathione to get rid of it completely out of the body.
So here's SOD.
It takes superoxide, that guy right there, and it gets rid of it.
It turns it into a hundred of peroxide.
Then this is the glutathione cycle.
It can't elase and eventually turns it into water.
It gets it out of the body.
If you have excess, it excess nitric oxide, that's that NO.
And it takes this ODO, which is proxy nitrite.
Easy, easy, right?
Easy, easy, you got this down.
So we want to support that pathway if you have defects on that.
The glutathione pathway comes from the bottom half of that picture that I just showed.
Glutathione is one of the cells most important antioxidants.
If you don't make enough glutathione, you're making all sorts of different things.
So glutathione is essential to support this pathway as well.
You got a question?
Yes.
So the NOS defects, so let's go back to our picture here.
If I have excess superoxide, that's by itself a free radical that can damage cells.
If I have excess free nitric oxide, which will come from a chronic infection,
so if I have a chronic, some clinical infection like H. Pylori,
and I don't even know it, I'll have excess nitric oxide.
If I have a known chronic infection like Lyme, I'll have excess nitric oxide.
You couple those two problems together, SODG defects plus excess nitric oxide.
That's how you produce excess proxy nitrate.
You'll also get excess nitric oxide if you have it OSG defects.
So you might not have any chronic infection.
I don't have H. Pylori, I don't have Lyme,
but I have NOS defects plus SODG defects.
You have proxy nitrate formation.
So the NOSG is in the biopteran cycle that makes endothelial nitric oxide.
But if I have defects of that, I will have a couple of these of that,
and have excess nitric oxide flowed free flowed into the body.
But any product, there's three types of nitric oxide.
Sinochydiducymal nitric oxide, which is going to be in a chronic infection,
you're going to have ramped up that.
So any chronic infection is going to cause excess nitric oxide.
And then the endothelial cells in the neurotal.
So those three forms.
Glutathione is important.
How to take that is important.
You don't always want to take just glutathione.
It's not really well absorbable.
The new types of glutathione as acetyl glutathione are much better to be absorbed.
But typically, I don't even use that.
We use glutathione support because glutathione is recycled.
And if you support that recycling to glutathione,
sometimes that's the best way to do it.
It catalyzes the other gene that you want to look at.
So if you look at the whole gene picture,
then you could go, wow, this person definitely has problems with proxy nitrate
or whatever you're trying to correct with this person.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
So if you took liposomal glutathione,
yeah, that's fine.
That's another form of glutathione.
But again, we don't want to just,
we have to be careful, too.
Remember, too much of a good thing is bad thing.
So we don't want to just push one pathway.
That's the danger of, oh, I had my empty it too far.
I am a positive defect on 6, 7, 7.
So I started taking 5 grams of folate
in the methyl comolate V12.
Is that a bad thing?
Yeah, probably.
Did you look at your biopsyrate pathway?
Because folate is going to heavily push that.
And if you have comp defects,
I met people call it say,
I would have folate in methyl comolate,
and I felt like I was going to kill somebody.
Yeah, because your dopamine in serotonin went through the rough.
You'll see that as we get to that.
You have to be careful with too much of anything
that you think is a good thing.
Oh, glutathione, I read this book, I glutathione.
So I'm going to take all this glutathione, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
These are all a bit about pathways that are just literally flying.
And you're just going to feed one.
It's going to throw things out.
You have to be careful.
You're sighting from a P450 pathway.
So now we're in, this is detoxification pathways.
This is mainly in your liver.
You're sighting a Crow P450 pathway
as your main primary detox,
what have you made, primary detox pathways in your liver.
This person has, not too real, they got enough defects out there.
So again, how do we get rid of poisons in our body
through these pathways?
If these pathways are compromised,
we're going to have issues.
This is an interesting, this specific ABP1 gene was researched.
This is how you get rid of that steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs in your body.
Oh, I don't do good with Tylenol, I take Tylenol, and I just feel sick.
Yeah, well, you probably have this gene defect.
Or as a doctor, you're going to look at that person's gene defect
so they don't have that.
But let's say they have a two there,
so they have a double allele defect of that gene,
or they're not going to prescribe those.
They don't get rid of them very well.
These are the people that take Tylenol or Tylenol
and they don't have a liver failure,
because they can't detoxify it.
Remember, you are what you don't detoxify.
So if I have a patient that comes to me,
it says, I started with, I have stage 4 cancer,
and I did chemo, and I just absolutely crashed.
I can't handle it.
Okay, well, is it just because they emotionally can't handle it?
Well, maybe there's a component of emotions in this,
but you have to look at their metabolic pathways.
They probably couldn't handle it,
because they have a whole bunch of cytochrome P450 pathway defects,
this defect, and pond pathway defect will talk about a second.
They can't get rid of these chemicals very well.
Therefore, if you knew this before you decided to do some course of a event,
would it be a good idea?
Hey, I can't do that drug,
because I don't get rid of it very well,
or I need to do a much lower dosage.
In Arabic, medicine, these people are called monotypes,
before we do anything about genetics.
People that can take one fifth the dosage of something
and that's all they can handle,
because they can't handle anymore.
Well, most likely, they have genetic defects in their ability to get rid of it.
And if you dose them too high, you can hurt them,
even with specific new treats.
Okay, so I've said before,
one of the more difficult things that I have to do with a cancer patient,
or a lying patient, is divorce them from everything that they're currently tanking,
this giant blood remascus full of supplements that they have.
Too much of a good thing is a bad thing.
You take something and you absorb it,
and your body can't use it, guess who has to detoxify it?
You're a liver.
If you're overwhelming,
you're liver detoxification pathways,
even if they're perfectly open,
those things are going to stay in your body
and they can negatively affect you.
So looking at your detoxification pathways
can be extremely helpful.
Your pond one pathway is where you get rid of pesticides,
insecticides, large chemicals.
What happened there?
Keep hitting buttons, what am I supposed to do?
Large chemicals and drugs,
you get rid of the pond one pathway.
This person has a number of detox in there.
They don't get rid of those very well.
So this is where I say,
you better not be sprayed your load.
You better not be, you know,
you better be sure you're eating the clean 15
and staying away from the nerdy dozen,
or value those organic.
You better make sure you're not using insecticides and chemicals
and fertilizers and all that garbage in your house.
You're better off making,
everybody's better off making those decisions.
But definitely if you have compromise
in your site of growth before 50 of your pond pathways
and the NAT pathways I'm going to talk about in a little bit,
you really have to watch those things even more so.
And this is where you start getting into the question,
do vaccinations cause autism?
Because I don't believe it,
but my neighbor believes it.
Well, I really care what you believe.
But the truth is, vaccinations
and the things that are in a vaccination
have to be detoxed through different pathways.
If you have a six pound baby
with pond one pathway,
site of growth P450 pathways
and MTHFR pathway defects,
you better believe they're going to cause problems.
You can't be saved enough
that they're going to cause problems.
This child has no blood and brain barrier.
That's not formed yet.
So you take a six pound baby
and you're going to inject all these adjemokes
for this vaccination you know,
and not knowing what their genetic pathways are,
well, you might as well just play Russian or Latin.
So I tell parents,
okay, you're going to have a kid,
really good idea for you and your husband
to get it 23 and be done.
And then you can make it in four decisions
regardless of what you believe
whether vaccinations work or not.
We won't get into that,
because I can talk about that for five hours.
But if you know what your detoxification pathways are,
you know whether you're going to give minimum or not.
Okay?
So if the husband and the wife have a lot of defects in that,
chance in that kid,
you put up a little graph,
here's you,
you have a two,
so one of the one,
your husband has a one,
they have a 50% chance of having a two,
they have a 100% chance of having a one.
You want to take the chance?
Maybe a different way to achieve immunization
would be better.
All right?
Oh, I didn't know I had a slide on that.
Your NAT pathways,
your NAT pathways,
are a specific genetic pathway
that you get rid of,
like everyday toxins,
like cigarette smoke,
and chart coal,
and everything that you're exposed to
that is just everywhere.
So you look at somebody
who I have a small fur,
I smoke three packs a day,
do they have NAT pathways that look like that?
Your chance of low kids are going up.
So if you know people,
I know people,
I've lived a hundred and five years old,
they smoke five packs a day.
Why?
Well they probably didn't have any of those D defects.
Yes.
So then you go,
then you start asking the question,
where did these defects come from
and because of the cigarette smoke
that caused that defect,
right?
Very possibly.
So their children might have a higher likelihood
of having that defect.
Yes.
So further studies down the road
are going to take place of this.
That's going to be interesting.
Yeah, the epigenetic factors.